february 2002
colombian trade union leader gilberto
torres had been receiving threats for
months he was fighting against human
rights abuses and environmental damages
in colombia caused by bp the british
petroleum company
and when another trade union leader was
killed fighting for the same cause
taurus organized several oil workers
strikes to send bp a message
you can't abuse colombia and its
citizens like that
not under my watch
there was just one problem these strikes
would cause a lot of damage to bp's
bottom line
quite a dangerous endeavor especially in
colombia
like most oil companies in colombia bp
had a special deal with the colombian
government they paid one dollar a barrel
a kind of additional tax and in return
they would get special protection of
their oil facilities
and who would carry out that special
protection colombia's very own para
military
and these paramilitary death squads had
a clear task protect these oil pipelines
at all costs with kidnappings and
bullets if necessary
so after organizing all these strikes
and protests gilberto torres became
their number one enemy
after a long day of work gilberto torres
was tired and ready to go home on his
way home a van filled with security
forces drove past him thinking nothing
of it he honked his phone to greet them
and kept driving but moments later
torres saw that the van had turned
around and was following him
what was going on had his time come
as the car caught up with him he turned
around to look at them and was suddenly
staring down the barrel of a gun
they rammed him with full force and that
was the point he realized there was no
chance of escaping they got him out of
the car handcuffed and blindfolded him
and threw him into the back of their van
his worst nightmare had come true
he was in the hands of the death squad
and they showed him first hand how they
do business
first they forced taurus to watch as
they tortured another prisoner after the
man told him what they wanted to hear
they shot him twice in the neck
and then they proceeded to do something
to his body that we can't talk about on
youtube without being demonetized
the next day his kidnappers threw him in
a hole filled with giant red ants and
covered it with barbed wire and to
torture him even more psychologically
they told him that they also kidnapped
his wife and son
he was close to losing all hope but then
something strange happened
one morning as taurus was preparing for
another day of torture the commander
told him to put on some nice clothes
because he was gonna be on camera what
taurus didn't know was that his trade
union colleagues had threatened more
national oil strikes if they didn't let
taurus go and it worked
after six weeks of brutal interrogation
and 10 days in a pit infested with red
ants taurus was let go and his survival
meant that his captors would be brought
to trial and who were his captors the
self-defense forces of castinari one of
colombia's most feared paramilitary
units and they made a shocking
confession
oh sensa the oil pipeline partly owned
and operated by the british oil giant bp
had ordered the hit on gilberto taurus
the price a hundred million pesos around
forty thousand dollars
in court the paramilitary commander
stated they were the ones that asked us
to execute this man not that we kidnap
him but to seize him kill him and make
him disappear
this man organized too many shutdowns
too many unions too many strikes
just so we're clear here an oil pipeline
partly controlled by bp had paid
mercenaries forty thousand dollars to
execute an activist because he was
organizing strikes against their
pipeline
but due to public pressure they were
forced to let him go and gilberto torres
has been living in exile ever since
but as far as bp is concerned these
confessions are just some wild
allegations by some ruthless killers
to this day bp denies any involvement in
the kidnappings and killings by the
paramilitary to protect their precious
oil pipelines
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at
jaketren and you're automatically
entered a few of you have won already
watch out for fake accounts i will never
message you asking for money and this is
bp the most evil business in the world
[Music]
[Music]
high risk people like gilberto torres
need to take their online security
extremely seriously for obvious reasons
but contrary to popular belief you
shouldn't need to be super paranoid to
take your online security seriously the
internet is a part of all of our careers
even if you don't work online because if
you get compromised online you can get
your identity sold like someone does
every 14 seconds you could get your
money stolen your crypto stolen your
instagram could be hacked like i'm sure
has happened to some of you or your
friends your credit score could be
ruined you could set your life back by
years all because of a simple cyber
crime and guess what all these cyber
crimes are just getting more and more
popular so it's not a matter of if
you'll be a victim but when
the problem is protecting yourself
online used to mean paying for a bunch
of different apps a vpn a password
manager identity that protection fraud
monitoring anti-virus software it is a
lot and just like that you're paying
around 50 a month or more for all these
different services which is totally out
of the budget for most people so
wouldn't it be cool if all these vital
services could be combined into an
all-in-one affordable app well you're in
luck because that is where today's video
sponsor comes in aura aura is making
sure that everyone can protect
themselves online
honestly guys i thought i was pretty
safe online but after i signed up for
aura and fit out some simple information
about myself they were able to discover
that my information had already been
leaked on a dark web six different times
just that alone makes it worth signing
up for aura's 14 day free trial with the
link below at aura.com jake just to make
sure you don't have any sensitive
information floating around on the dark
web already but there is a lot more you
can use aura to monitor your bank
accounts for sketchy transactions you
can use it to track and lock your credit
score right within the app locking your
credit score is super important but also
really tedious but or unless you do it
right within the app and you can also
download their antivirus software to run
scans on your computer every single day
automatically and whenever or detect
something suspicious with any of these
things you'll immediately get a text on
your phone which is super handy or
provides 247 support every day of the
year and they have a 60 day money back
guarantee and you get all of this stuff
with just one affordable subscription so
start protecting yourself from america's
fastest growing crime today by going to
aura.com jake with the link below to get
your first two weeks for free so pause
the video and go to aura.com jake and
thanks to aura for sponsoring this video
[Music]
in 1901 the british businessman and
millionaire william knox darcy decided
to start a new venture he set out to
look for oil in iran he offered the shah
of iran a deal if darcy found any oil in
iran he owns them and in exchange the
iranian government would get twenty
thousand pounds in cash twenty thousand
pounds in stocks and only 16 of the
future profits discovering oil in your
own country would be a gold mine so for
any government with a bit of
self-respect this would be a
ridiculously bad deal but since iran's
government doesn't have the know-how to
drill for oil the shah had no choice but
to agree
16 of something is better than 100 of
nothing after all and all that money
would go straight into the shah's
pockets so he could live an even more
luxurious life
after the deal was made darcy hired a
geologist to search for oil in the
iranian desert but it wasn't the cozy
adventure they had imagined
smallpox raged bandits and warlords
freely roamed the desert there was
little to no fresh water and the
devastating heat of the iranian desert
didn't make the job any easier years
went by without finding a single drop of
oil and darcy's fortune started to
shrink by 1908 darcy had sunk more than
500 000 pounds into his risky venture
even for a multi-millionaire that's a
huge investment and it looked like it
wasn't going to pay off so darcy decided
that it was time to pack the bags and
leave iran he sent a message to his
geologist telling him that he was
running out of money and that he needs
to abort the mission but his geologist
wasn't ready to give up yet so he
ignored the message and kept going and
only a few days later in a last-ditch
effort he finally struck oil
suddenly darcy was the sole owner of a
vast ocean of oil and thanks to the deal
he made with the shaw no one else was
allowed to drill or sell iranian oil
except for him and he was set to be
richer than his wildest dreams
on april 14th 1909 the anglo-persian oil
company was born and the shipping of
persian oil products began in 1913 from
their new refinery in abaddon as iranian
oil production ramped up the british
empire started enjoying a new era of
immense wealth but the iranian people
they were still dirt poor even the oil
workers at the abaddon refinery were
still dirt poor
they were paid 50 cents a day and had to
live in a shanty town they were
surrounded by mud stagnant water and
biting flies without clean water or
electricity these hard-working iranians
were literally giving away the country's
most precious resource to the british
basically for free while they were
living in devastating poverty the mass
majority
of france
they were treating them kind of like the
way we treated black americans in
pre-civil war south or even post civil
war south when we put them in economic
slavery instead of real slavery fast
forward to 1913 shortly before world war
one and winston churchill was facing a
problem for one he wanted to modernize
britain's royal navy and get rid of all
the ships that were still running on
coal but another problem was the
british's dependence on standard oil
john d rockefeller's american oil empire
the british government wanted to turn
the anglo-persian oil company into their
own oil empire so they wouldn't have to
rely on the americans and with world war
one just around the corner they didn't
have any time to waste so the government
bought 51 of the shares in the
anglo-persian oil company making them
the controlling power behind the oil
company now with the british government
calling the shots and a world war going
on the british oil business started
booming during the 1920s 30s and 40s the
british empire was fueled by iranian oil
british cars trucks and factories all
ran on cheap iranian oil the royal navy
powered its ships with
[Music]
and the iranians they didn't even get
their measly 16 cut the british
government paid them a pitiful 47 000
pounds while they made millions from
their oil it was one of the most
ruthless and one-sided deals in the
history of business and winston
churchill later wrote fortune brought us
a prize from fairyland beyond our
wildest dreams
the oil coming from iran brought
millions in revenue to the british
treasury
under the original agreement
only about 16 of the oil revenue was
supposed to be given to iran
but
that 16 was going to be calculated by
the british and no iranian would be
allowed to look at the books
we now know also that the amount was
calculated after the oil company paid
its taxes now the oil company was owned
by the british government so when it was
paying taxes it was essentially paying
taxes to itself so it was a lot of
creative accounting but in the end it
was clear that almost all the money from
this tremendous resource was going into
britain and almost none was coming back
to iran but this ruthless deal was
leading to some tension iran shah or
king reza pelevi was a tough military
man who ruled over iran with an iron
fist and he can no longer accept how the
british were exploiting his country he
demanded a better deal for iran's oil
but the british were quite happy with
the contract and simply stalled
negotiations until the shah threatened
to cancel it as a result the british
made a concession
they agreed to pay about a million
pounds a year and since the shah didn't
like the name persia they also changed
the company's name to anglo-iranian oil
company
iran had finally gotten something out of
the deal but it was still a slap in the
face
just a million pounds a year for the
billions of dollars the british oil
company would continue to make it was
ridiculous
the oil company also promised to
increase the oil workers salaries build
schools hospitals and roads but those
promises would also not be fulfilled on
to get back at the british the shah
started doing business with the germans
during world war ii you know the enemy
of the british so for the british that
was the last excuse they needed to get
rid of the shah for good so in august
1941 the british and soviets started a
military assault to overthrow the shawl
on the outside it was all about
defeating the evil germans and their
allies
but deep down it was all about securing
all that precious oil bubbling below
iran's soil one month later they
disposed of the shah and put his son
muhammad rezabel on the throne
[Music]
but muhammad wasn't anything like his
father he was more like a smooth talking
politician instead of a ruthless king
and at only 21 years old and born into
power he would have a hard time keeping
a powerful nation like the british at
bay
[Music]
[Music]
after world war ii the idea of
nationalism swept through the developing
world and in iran that meant one thing
we've got to take back our oil from the
evil british the iranian people were
tired of handing over their precious oil
to the british more or less for free
while the shah and the british continued
to amass more and more wealth something
had to change and from the ashes rose
one man that promised to take on both
the british and the shah to give iran
back to its people and that man went by
the name of muhammad mosaddegh mosaddegh
was a man of integrity an incorruptible
politician who wanted to turn iran into
a wealthy well-educated nation
and on april 28 1951 mossadeg became
iran's new prime minister with the full
support of its people he promised that
from now on oil profits would be used to
develop iran not in rich britain and
fortunately he was one of the few
leaders who actually followed through
with his words
only a few days later he nationalized
the anglo-iranian oil company which
meant that he took the oil industry back
from the british and put the iranian
government in charge of it
now finally had the chance to make a
better living for themselves and over
the next few decades it could even turn
iran into one of the wealthiest
countries in the world and the british
they were fuming
to them taking their most lucrative
business away from them was an act of
war so the british removed their
technicians from iran's oil fields they
blockaded the port they cut off exports
of vital goods to iran and they
organized a full-blown boycott of
iranian oil the iranians were completely
on their own without the know-how or
connections to drill and sell their oil
they were back to square one but their
hatred for the british was so intense
that they would never give up
little did they know that the british
government was only getting started for
the british it was time to overthrow
this mosaid guy so the british turned to
washington with a simple request please
overthrow mohammed mosaddeg for us so we
can have our oil back but harry truman
the u.s president at that time didn't
see the point of a u.s intervention in
iran the u.s didn't have any skin in
this fight so he rejected the request
for a moment the british thought about
invading iran themselves but then dwight
eisenhower became the next u.s president
in november 1952. he was a devoted
anti-communist and so was his secretary
of state john dulles
so as soon as it was announced
eisenhower would be the next president
mi6 britain's version of the cia sent an
agent to america to discuss
possibilities
the british told the americans that
nationalization and land reform sounded
a lot like something called communism
that communists had infiltrated the
iranian government that if the u.s
doesn't act now the entire middle east
could fall into communism
in 1953 the cia got the green light for
operation ajax their mission get
mosaddegh out of the government dead or
alive
less than a month later most of egg was
overthrown the shah was back in power
and the british by the end of 1953 the
anglo-iranian oil company resumes its
usual operations this time it was
renamed to something that might sound a
little familiar bp or the british
petroleum company
the iran coup of 1953 was the first time
the cia had overthrown a democratic
government to the cia it was one of the
most successful covert operations in
their entire history but little did they
know that this one small act of
aggression this one decision to strip
away the iranian people's control over
their country's own destiny would be the
first domino to fall in what would lead
to some of the biggest terror attacks in
the world
the iranian coup of 1953 sowed the seeds
of middle eastern terror
but to cover the entire iran coup of
1953 and the terror that followed would
not only be beyond the scope of this
video but would also get this video
demonetized that's why we've just
released it as a new private documentary
only available to members of this
channel that you can watch right now by
clicking the join button below channel
members have been loving it and if you
join and you don't think it's worth it
email us within your first month of
joining and we will personally refund
you for your first month after your
first month there is no refund pause the
video and click that join button below
right now now back to the story of bp
[Music]
date april 20 2010 location bp's
deepwater horizon oil rig 41 miles off
the coast of louisiana it was a
perfectly calm night at around 1955 crew
members checked the pressure readings on
the well to see if it was under control
despite some anomalies the test didn't
raise any concerns it looked like just
another night on the oil rig but below
their feet a storm was brewing at 2138
gas burst through the well and into the
pipe leading up to the rig a few minutes
later mud began raining down on the deck
and the crew made a call to shut down
the well but it was too late
one siren signal after another went off
while the pressure of the drill pipe
skyrocketed
2149 four minutes after they made the
call to shut the well the power went out
the oil rig plunged into darkness
a few seconds later all hell broke loose
two massive explosions shook the oil rig
to its core some of the men were forced
to jump 60 feet into the water so they
wouldn't be engulfed in flames
in a last desperate attempt to get the
situation under control the crew tried
to get the blowout preventer in place
the ultimate fail-safe on the ocean
floor but it failed
at around 10 pm the mayday call went out
deepwater horizon was lost
[Music]
11 people died
17 more were injured
and in the three months after the
accident 210 million gallons of crude
oil leaked into the gulf of mexico
coasts of several u.s states and mexico
were damaged and fishing businesses in
the gulf of mexico came to a grinding
halt
it was the biggest oil catastrophe in
u.s history the obvious cause of the
explosion was that gas had floated up
through the drill and ignited into a
fireball but the real reason was bp's
endless greed and recklessness
leasing the deepwater horizon cost bp
one million dollars a day and they had
fallen way behind schedule
so they brushed aside any concerns that
could slow down the drilling and
threaten their profits
it was later found out that bp's flawed
well design cracks in the cement and
other cost-saving decisions that
increase the risk of an accident were
all ignored no one dared to put a stop
to the oil production to ensure a safer
working environment the pressure to
maximize profits and make shareholders
happy was too big so they ignored
another kind of pressure during the
public outrage bp took responsibility
for the accident and over the years
they'd have to pay 65 billion dollars
for the cleanup and fines including more
than 10 billion dollars to u.s fishermen
and businesses
but mexico they allegedly didn't receive
a single penny bp simply denied that the
oil had reached mexico at all but in
mexico they knew better
before the accident about 95 percent of
the villages along the mexican coast
made a living from fishing they were
famous for their prawns and oysters but
after the accident fishing businesses
were as good as dead
young people were forced to seek factory
work in far away cities to support their
families and it could take 20 to 25
years for the ecosystem to recover from
the contamination will anyone ever go to
jail for this accident of course not
u.s prosecutors dropped manslaughter
charges against two bp employees
connected to the oil spill disaster they
didn't even go after bp's executives
just normal employees
the father of 28 year old gordon jones
who died in the deepwater horizon
explosion said the fact that no one will
ever spend a moment behind bars for
having killed 11 men by their greed by
their negligence based entirely on greed
is astonishing to me
hope you guys enjoyed the video today
don't forget we just released a new
private documentary on the 1953 iranian
coup and the roots of middle eastern
terror super super good video i'm very
proud of it and you can watch it right
now by clicking that join button below
remember you can follow me on instagram
jaytran for a chance to win a thousand
dollars but that's gonna wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you